[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here so
earlier in the year you might remember
we did a video on that in glass
fingerprint reader you know all these
bezel-less phones are coming out now
there's no room on the front for a
fingerprint reader unless you put it
underneath the glass so we got to see a
demo of it in action in an unreleased
vivo phone well today of course now we
have that phone it's here it's in the
studio it's the vivo x21 and it's out
now it exists snapdragon 660 six gigs of
ram 3200 milliamp hour battery and a 6.3
inch 1080p oled display with of course
the optical fingerprint sensor
underneath so now that we have it in the
flesh it kind of feels like we have no
choice but to uh
test the limits of it or push it to the
limit so okay quick refresher on how
this works you can watch the entire
original video for the full rundown but
basically this is a small optical sensor
underneath the glass of an oled display
and the sensor itself is really small
it's maybe the size of a fingernail and
when we say optical sensor we literally
mean it's the oled shining up light to
reflect off of your finger and the
sensor reading the reflection of your
finger to see the fingerprint so
naturally there are a couple possible
limitations to this just because of how
the technology works that we can think
of but you know there's limitations with
touch id too but if we're going to see
this in the future of smartphones you
know on a possible future iphone or a
samsung phone down the road then it's
worth exploring now so i have my
fingerprint registered here my right
thumb and i'll go ahead and register my
left thumb as well so you can see how it
works but it's pretty similar to any
other fingerprint reader like touch id
you press down over and over again and
it gets multiple reads of the same
finger it's a little slower and more
deliberate right now but it learns it it
saves it and then you do the edges too
so you're nice and thorough and that's
it so now it has two fingers it's got
the right thumb that's fingerprint
number one and the left is fingerprint
two so obviously a fingerprint reader
doesn't work when your fingers are
covered like with a glove on or
something like that but what if your
finger's just slightly covered
so all right without water on my hands
it works perfectly but we've all been
sweaty or been in the rain for a minute
or had our hands wet and we go to unlock
our phone and it can get interesting
here it's not rejecting me it's just
having a hard time reading my finger
it's saying you know press deeper it's
not getting a very good read i'm
actually not surprised though like if i
bring out the iphone 8 here with touch
id you're gonna see the same thing
actually it works perfectly right now
but if i get a little water on my hand
here it doesn't work as well so there's
no real advantage or disadvantage with
water here but being underneath the
display glass i'm sure doesn't help
anything water has always been a nemesis
of displays but you're gonna have to
wipe your finger and get it a little
more dry and then it'll go through no
problem
all right here's a little bit of a
spicier test so let's say you're eating
some hot wings maybe you're maybe you're
at lunch with someone and you want to
answer your phone you get a phone call
but you don't have time to wipe your
fingers but you still got to unlock now
i would guess that this would also not
work basically for the same reason that
water doesn't work but also because if
your finger is dirty in any way the
sauce or the dirt or whatever it is
that's on your hand it'll kind of fill
in the gaps in your fingerprint and
it'll look different to the optical
sensor and sure enough saucy fingers do
not work i'll try it on the iphone as
well for good measure
but yeah as you can see it doesn't go
through phones just don't like saucy
fingers and this new underglass
fingerprint reader uh won't get you out
of this one but we have another idea
which was it's just dusty fingers so we
got the sun chips out and basically i'm
gonna i'm gonna get enough dust on my
fingers to like when you're getting to
the end of the bag we've all been there
uh let's see how it holds up so the
in-glass fingerprint reader
it's not seeing me okay so that's a
negative and if i try touch id
actually touch id on the iphone does
unlock wow so okay touch id saw enough
info on that first swipe to verify it's
my fingerprint but the underglass vivo
didn't uh but then actually after a
couple more tries it does work so
another question that actually came up
in the comments of the first video is
screen protector will an in-glass
fingerprint reader work with a screen
protector on your phone well i can
already actually answer that yes and i
know that because actually i have two of
these and they come in the box with the
screen protector on by default it's a
standard fingerprint reader cuts around
the notch and everything you can see
that right so that goes over the glass
it doesn't affect the optical sensor
because it can still see through that
fingerprint reader no problem it doesn't
obscure the optics in any way but that
got me of course thinking about other
screen protectors you can get all types
of other screen protectors you can get
tempered glass screen protectors i'm
sure we've all seen those and the final
level which is the glass privacy shield
so it's basically polarized so you can't
view it off axis it's one of those
maximum security screen protectors so
let's try the regular glass first it is
still clear and i'm going to go ahead
and put it right over the sensor
obviously this phone is brand new it
just came out so i'm pretty sure there
are no glass screen protectors made for
it but this one just has cutouts for an
iphone but there you go completely
covered no bubbles or anything and if we
give it a shot
that is success
okay so no hesitation there that was
pretty much exactly the same as if it
didn't have a screen protector on
confirmed you can use a tempered glass
screen protector with this reader the
privacy shield though it's getting
pretty intense
but believe it or not as much as i hate
them a lot of people use these on the
daily you know got to keep that person
behind you on the train from being able
to read your messages
so there you go fully protected
but does your in-glass fingerprint
reader still work
yes it does wow i was actually gonna i
probably would have bet against that uh
the privacy shield really messes with
the optics if you even try to look
through one it gets really funky but
apparently that's no problem so very
cool good to know that the future of
smartphones should have no problem with
this all right so how many people do you
know with uh with those shattered screen
protectors that they just leave on their
phones so just like that i'm gonna leave
this shattered screen protector on this
phone with the cracks going up over the
fingerprint sensor i mean that's kind of
how it would crack it's from the corner
and we'll give that a shot
wow no problem it felt actually felt a
little slower that time
but it definitely worked
yeah really slow but success is success
so you can't always take the screen
protector off and get a new one
immediately but if you're the type of
person to leave it on you can do that
and get a new one later so that just
leaves us with my final experiment which
is
simulated
extreme wear and tear you see micro
scratches these things happen right you
take this thing in and out of your
pocket hundreds of times a week maybe
even hundreds of times a day there's
gonna be wear and tear there's gonna be
little things in your pocket little
abrasions from the particles around you
it's unavoidable it's painful to make
them by myself on purpose with a box
cutter but it's every phone i've ever
had has gotten these scratches on the
screen so here's where we're at
and if we
give that a shot
no problem right the knife is a little
harder and the scratches are a little
more real this might be more like a year
of wear and tear like a year later type
of scenario if you take pretty good care
of your phone
but still no problem you're probably
noticing this whole time that the reader
isn't quite as fast as touch id that's
for sure it's still just where the
technology is right now no doubt it's
gonna be getting faster with time like
touch id did all right uh let's
accelerate
this like way faster cover your eyes
kids
man i hate doing this but for science
that's what it looks like
and the reader still works
a little more a little more
that's uh
that's pretty good look at how scratched
up this glass is right now i think it's
safe to say if your phone ever gets this
scratched up and your fingerprint reader
still works then you're probably good
for a long time like if your screen ever
looks like this you're probably in the
market for a new phone anyway i gotta
say that's some pretty solid results
with everything we just threw at it
nothing exceedingly great or way better
but also nothing exceedingly bad it's
kind of in this like middle ground but
that has me pretty pumped about it for
its development in the future of
smartphones see if you remember the
first generation of fingerprint readers
and smartphones the first gen touch id
it wasn't that great but it's it's had
time to develop and turn into the gold
standard that it is now for both speed
and accuracy and i kind of see that for
the future of this if this gets worked
on from all angles by a bunch of
different companies i could eventually
see this finding its way into a future
iphone a future samsung phone and maybe
even flagships in the next couple years
so that's pretty exciting
but until then
thanks for watching
talk to you in the next one
peace